I'm so excited to be here to be hosting
this very special edition of the 2020
Kids Choice Awards Sammy we're gonna
have a great time let's do this
Victoria Justice kicked off the
star-studded fun-filled night as the
host of Nickelodeon's first virtual Kids
Choice Awards in spite of the changes
due to the corona virus pandemic the
one-hour show was packed with famous
faces memorable at-home performances and
of course slime
[Applause]
we're breaking down the best moments
from the show kicking it off with Dwayne
the rock Johnson hey kids all around the
world the actor celebrated his 48th
birthday by taking home the award for
favorite movie actor I want to say thank
you so much from the bottom of my heart
for voting for me I want you to stay
positive I want you to stay happy I want
you to stay healthy I want you to go to
bed tonight feeling great because
however old you are around the world
just know that you are still bigger than
Kevin Hart I love you guys Shawn Mendes
and Camilla Kibeho won the favorite
music collaboration award for their
tracks and yareta
[Music]
we
[Music]
what's up guys thank you so much for the
Kids Choice work we love you so much
this is so cool Shawn also nabbed the
award for favorite male artist the
couple gave us all the fills with this
video message from quarantine we were
there to get fly I wish we could be
there with you but we hope that
everybody is staying safe we love you
thank you so much for voting we're gonna
make organic slime right now and just
fly ourselves now this next moment is
one that we just can't let go
[Music]
yep that's Kristen Bell dressed in a
princess on a costume accepting her
award you guys we had such a good time
making this film that we hope to make a
million more anybody else want to say
anything
No you guys want
[Music]
they're normally very talkative thank
you so much Josh GAD took things to
another level by accepting the trophy
for favorite male voice in a movie from
well thank you so much Millie Bobby
Brown chose to use her acceptance speech
for favorite female TV star as an
opportunity to thank those who are on
the frontlines of the pandemic I have a
deep respect for healthcare workers at
the forefront of all of this who are
risking their lives fighting for our
parents our grandparents children we
love and appreciate you so much
I cherish and admire their bravery work
and drive more than anyone Ellen
DeGeneres made sure to give viewers a
laugh as she accepted the award for
favorite TV host for her show game of
games this is a pretty weird time right
now and I know most of you can't be at
school right now I know you miss your
friends you probably miss your teachers
because a real teacher has got to be
better than your mother and old pajamas
anyway hang in there and know that even
though this is a really hard time it
will not last forever
now I got a zoom literally I have a zoom
meeting LeBron James was honored with
the special generation change award
during Saturday's show and also took
home the blimp for favorite male athlete
wow you want to say thank you you guys
are amazing Nickelodeon you guys are
amazing
thanks so much for what you guys do for
every kid in the world and this is
always been one of the best show to be a
part of so thank you so much hopefully
you see you guys soon stay safe and stay
healthy
love you guys BTS accepted the award for
favorite music group all the way from
Korea
Asher Angel wild fans with a special
performance of his song all day ariana
grande took a moment to reflect back on
her nickelodeon days while accepting the
award for favorite female artist
nickelodeon always will hold such a
tremendous place in my heart not only
because of victorious and salmon cat and
amazing years as then working with them
but also just first punch Bob you know
so I've always I'm always very honored
to be part and I want to say thank you
so much for all your love and fern
making me your favorite female music
style the favorite social media star
award went to Joe Josie wahoo raved
about how the network has played a part
in some of the best times of her life
right now only gonna make life bigger
and better I love you all so much and
thank you again the show ended with the
bank as the cast of Avengers in game
accepted the award for favorite movie
got stay safe stay strong
Trigon which don't get together we'll
get through this whatever it takes
love you 3000
[Music]